3 o' ladies and gentlemen so it's time
to start
um afternoon and welcome to the
regulatory
committee my name is j councelor Jenny F
I think you know that um alongside
members of the committee I'm joined
today by uh K Keller Democratic service
officer and CLA Enon planning manager
and Paul Reed environmental health and
Li licensing
manager
um the form yeah I just read through it
actually committee members when invited
to address the meeting please ensure
your microphone is switched on so that
it it is picked up VI the live audio
feed when You' finished addressing the
meeting please turn off your microphone
immediately please ensure you've
switched off or to silent or any or all
your devices have will not interrupt the
proceedings please note this is meeting
is also being broadcast live and members
of the public not in attendance today
are able to view the proceedings we now
move to the agenda uh apologies for
absence please we have apologies from
councilors Mills petrovich and Wally
hoggins thank
you disclosures of interest do any
committee members have any interest that
would they would like to declare in
relation to items on the
agenda if there are any points members
wish to raise please indicate otherwise
I'll oh sorry now we go to the
minutes so if there are any points
members wish to raise please indicate
otherwise I'll take the minutes as
noted no thank
you minutes of subcommittees
if there are any points members wish to
raise please indicate otherwise I'll
take the minutes as
noted thank
you public participation number
five nonone receive from the public
counselor questions nonone receive from
counselors so item number seven will go
directly to the enforcement dat I invite
CLA Enon to present her
report okay thank you
chair this is the regular report that
you should be familiar with the format I
start on page 23 has got a breakdown of
the cases received for the last four
years you'll see for the last year 2023
we had
577 cases um I've done some research
before this committee and of those
577 141 and were declined to investigate
so perhaps the numbers aren't as high as
what the the table might have suggested
um I am going to look into patterns more
about the decline to investigate to see
um whether we're recording those
correctly because for the year before
there was only 56 that we declined so
obviously there's been a significant
jump in the last 12 months so I need to
have a look into why we're doing that
whether it's the the right type of
action but just to give you some
reassurance we only declined to
investigate after some initi
investigation to check that we should be
declining we don't just rush into that
decision
process on page 24 there's a table which
shows a breakdown of some of the
historic cases um we still have the
oldest case dating back to 2016 which is
relating to a scheme that requires
Highway work so it's something that
we're waiting for the county to actually
Implement those
Works um the total number of cases on
hand as of this week is
275 which is the highest it's been for a
good number of years we did get just
below 200 um within the last 12 months
or so so it is
exceeding um we've also got some change
in resources which are going to happen
in the next two weeks um our most
long-standing officer who's been with us
for 20 years is retiring in two weeks
that post will be replaced by an officer
that was on a temporary contract so
we're not going to have a net increase
in offices if anything there will be a
reduction we've also had a temporary
officer that's with us until May that
person will be leaving in May with the
post not proposed to be filled so we'll
be down to three enforcement officers
from may just to let you
know um in terms of enforcement action
taken despite only having one senior for
most of last year we did still manage to
um take a lot of formal action which is
on the table on page 25 so we serve six
enforcement notices six breach of
condition notices and four temporary
stop notices this year already we've
served seven notices so it's more than
what's in the report um we've also
served seven planning contention notices
so we are now trying to proceed with
action on cases that we've identified
for action but as explained at previous
meetings we do have to be mindful that
if there's an appeal against an
enforcement notice we have to make sure
we've got the capacity to deal with
those Appeals fortunately we've not had
any appeals on any of the notices issued
since the end of August um but we did
serve a notice last week which I am
anticipating an appeal for and that will
likely to be a big appeal when it comes
through so we're just um holding fire at
the moment in terms of serving any new
major ones to make sure that we can deal
with
them um terms of the enforcement appeal
decisions we're still waiting for the
two that are set out on page
26 um link to um that the site that's
referred to as Palmer Manor we did have
a previous appeal decision for another
breach on that site and I also mentioned
a decision to decline to determine an
application on that site in February we
received confirmation from the high
court that they'd refus the application
for permission to apply for judicial
review against that decision however
we've now received notification that
they've applied for what's called a
renewal hearing which is to seek consent
to apply for judicial review so theyve
basically challenging that initial High
Court decision so again it seems to be a
delay tactic not to comply with the
enforcement notice that was issued some
time ago now um we are finding a pattern
now of the cases there we are taking
enforcement action they're not actually
complying with the notices so with the
financial money that we've got we've got
a pot of money left to spend this year
well for for the next 12 months we are
looking at other ways of spending that
money to potentially take direct action
where notices haven't been complied with
rather than having it on additional on
officers within the
team um so in terms of the report the
recommendation is that the report be
noted and I'm happy to answer any
questions thanks chair um thanks CLA um
the two I think it's said 275 cases
outstanding so and you mentioned that uh
the number of cases is coming in has
increased so is that due to Resource
complexity of the issues or the volume
of cases or all
three we' be interested just to know why
why those are running at the levels they
are or what patterns you can see it's a
combination of a number of factors um we
are getting more complicated breaches
being notified to us or certainly ones
that come in we're not finding reasons
that we can close cases that perhaps we
did before um we did um we have although
we've declined to um investigate some
cases so for last year 124 were no
breaches so of the
577 124 was no breach which is probably
slightly lower than what it had been in
previous years before I think it was 23
were no
breach yeah yeah um 77 we negotiated
last year so what we're finding is even
when we serve the formal notices because
people aren't complying we're actually
better off negotiating compliance from
the start rather than proceeding
straight to a notice because by serving
a notice it almost gives the person an
extra year not to comply because if they
appeal it's taking a year to get the
appeal decision so by negotiating you've
actually got the upper hand if they are
willing to enter into to those
negotiations but yeah for some
individuals that isn't appropriate and
you do have to go straight to
enforcement action
yeah brief thank thanks chair um so just
just for clarification because you
mentioned the the
124 declined um again um the the the
final figure of
260 those 124 will be included in the
closed figure anyway weren't they you
would have closed those off so the 26
275 they outstanding doesn't include the
that number does it there's no confusion
in the numbers so the total that um were
closed that were received in the same
year yeah let's have a
look I'd have
to put the microphone on it's just a
thought that the clo the closing number
if it included that it' be dis distorted
because effectively they
closed so you'll just come back to us on
that figure what I'll need to do is is
see how we report the breakdown of how
why cases that are closed and the
patterns to make sure that the figures
tally yeah um as part of the um peer
review that we're looking into and
looking at the local enforcement plan I
want to look at the data anyway for the
last couple of years to see what the
trends have been so I'll be doing that
exercise as part of that
review can I just ask a question as you
are now coming to three
full-time uh
staff is that going to be sufficient to
carry on the operation
with a degree of success that you're
having at the moment or will there be a
dip in in being able to uh follow all
these cases
through um under the structure it's
three enforcement officers who will do
the day-to-day investigations on
anything anything new that's reported we
also have two senior planners in the
team and it's the two senior planners
that progress cases to formal action so
they will help draft the notice and if
there's an appeal they will doal with
that appeal so we've got a combination
that we're doing the day-to-day
investigations and then progressing to
formal action we've got a schedule of
cases that need formal action already
that we're working our way through we
just have to bear in mind potential
appeals but there will be a very high
workload for those three Enforcement
Officers because that
275 will have to be split between those
three enforcement officers mainly and
previously they only had case load of 50
so it's going to be a very significant
increase so they'll have a high volume
of existing cases whilst also having to
deal with new cases that get reported so
we will have to prioritize very strictly
um according to the local enforcement
plan where we've got the critical trees
listed buildings that we do respond to
immediately significant that we will
then respond to to fall in the next
priority and the desirable ones might
have to fall off to some degree if
they're not causing significant planning
harm and that's where we'll be
contacting the W members to seek to
close those cases or to decline to
investigate at our next meeting could we
have a a fairly detailed response on
that as to how how that's working
because we I think I'd like to know
that the uh resource that we have is
actually managing to uh cope with work
thank
you I think that's what oh the mic's
just gone on thank you
Kira spooky I'm sorry
um so yes I think we need to have that
the next report
um CLA you also I didn't quite catch you
mentioned you said something about we
were holding fire on some a number of
Investigations could you just clarify
that again please it's more in terms of
taking formal action so we've made a
planning assessment that something is
expedient to take enforcement action but
if it needs an enforcement notice we're
having to almost put them in a queue
because because otherwise um what
happened last year we had three appeals
all arrive at the same time which then
meant that the senior couldn't do
anything else so we have to try and
phase them um but luckily when we serve
an enforcement notice we we know that
they only have 28 days to appeal so we
can diarize them every 28 days and
that's what we're trying to do at the
moment and because we've got two seniors
there is a little bit of flexibility
compared to what we've had for the last
12 months where we only had one senior
in the
team again I think maybe a little bit
more detail on how things are
prioritized for the next meeting might
be helpful chair I just want to last
Point CLA is that you mentioned a number
of staffing issues but in the report it
says there are no Staffing
implications so perhaps um if there are
Staffing implications or resources
issues that should actually be in in the
report because I think it's where it
says there are no staff no Human
Resources Staffing implications
associated with this report there
clearly are and I think that should be
in in the body of the report um you
mentioned the peer review it would be
helpful I think um to know more broadly
when that final report is being
published and when we will be seeing the
action plan because that is now nearly
six months since we first had that P
review so I think a number of us are
concerned more widely about the
rather long unforeseen delay in that but
that's a wider point but clearly it does
affect the enforcement thank you thank
you chair um I won't comment on the the
planning advisory service report um John
Kord may wish to comment but just in
terms of the Staffing implications I
would be cautious about putting too much
information in a public report because
the last thing we want is for the public
to realize that we haven't got as many
resources because otherwise it would
encourage more people to do breach and
at the moment we are getting a very high
number of people who are doing blatant
breaches and we certainly don't want to
encourage further such breaches but I
think my point is that reports that come
before this committee should be
comprehensive and I think there either
are Staffing implications or there are
not thank
you any other comments before we move on
to the next agenda
item councel thanks chair just very um
I've probably forgotten more than I've
remembered here but we we don't have the
the blue papers anymore so we don't
really know what's going on behind the
scenes and I understand you know the
need for uh most the time there's very
little change from from meeting to
meeting are we planning to publish those
um sort of every six months or every
year so we do see an an update or a
movement um going through you chair I
moved away from producing those lists
because I was worried that the committee
was starting to consider individual
cases without a full report on those
cases so this committee should only be
considering enforcement case that's been
referred to the committee under the
scheme of Delegation so that's why you
no longer have the blue sheets you will
obviously have cases that require
consideration by this committee but
there will be an individual case on that
specific item rather than lists of
multiple
cases
happy to move on to the next agenda item
thank you much CLA that's great thank
you um so on to item
seven uh sorry item eight environmental
health and Licensing update I invite
Paul Reed to present his report thank
you uh thank you chair uh I don't intend
to uh read it for Bon the reports there
for you all to see however I will
extract a few Salient points if I may
firstly starting on uh environmental
health section
2.1 uh food visits by our food team uh
we're on track to hopefully complete all
of our program food visits for for this
year uh following covid it's been quite
difficult the recovery plan has been
difficult the standards out there have
dropped significantly which has meant
increased work my office
uh and it means sometimes the
downgrading of some of the premises to
get them up to the required standard and
I think some premises are fearful for
themselves that their standards have
dropped and it's only when we actually
go and do the inspections do they really
realize that their standards are below
their own
expectations as well as those uh uh from
environmental health so we are on Target
and uh the there's very few local
authorities who are on target from a lot
of the group meetings that I go to so uh
so my food officers have been working
extremely hard to make sure that they're
fulfilling their quote of inspections
and I thank them for
that uh moving down on to
212 uh the national food crime unit did
send a request into us it's really
unusual for them to send a request in
especially when there little substance
to it and we did investigate that and we
didn't find that there was anything
really on toward actually happening uh
at the premise so it's nice that the
process is being followed through but uh
I do like it when my officers get their
teeth into something a little bit
juicier than
just that just a nothing complaint uh
the next item down a a food
complaint a sh of plastic in a national
Pizza chain uh was found the issue was
in the actual boxes that they come with
uh and the interventions of uh food
officers has meant that the head office
was informed uh and the primary
Authority and as a consequence the
storage boxes for the pizzas have been
removed and been replaced with a totally
different supplier so we was able to
marry up that piece of plastic with a
gap in a box so it was it was quite
fortuit us uh really uh the final item
on the food point of view is with
regards to the Victorian Market uh just
to say that my officers did spend some
time uh looking at the Victoria Market
it does do a lot of food uh Outlets
there uh we inspected 21 high-risk food
premises uh at the time the majority of
The
Independents were good in a good
standard however we did find that uh
some weren't uh uh and they've been
given a final opportunity to rectify
matters and I emphasize that word final
opportunity I wasn't happy I made it
crystal clear but I wasn't happy and my
officers have had a separate meeting
with them since
and they will be they tell me there's
going to be improvements for this year's
event I like most people the proof of
the pudding is in the eating I will see
it when I believe it and uh we will be
taking robust action uh if there aren't
improvements we cannot compromise on
food safety for one of the largest
defense in our district and I make no
apologies for my team robustly enforcing
the food the legislation ask a question
there these are the these are food
outlets at the Victorian Market if these
food Outlets come to the ordinary weekly
markets monthly markets uh are you still
looking at them in the same way in case
they're not coming up to
standard uh yes chair we do look at them
in exactly the same way all three
businesses get registered with a home
Authority and then we as an authority
look to do some routine sampling and
inspection
as of when they come into our district
so we do this at numerous events uh up
and down our district uh and we will go
and do some sampling at
them uh moving on to uh Den
noise uh we an ongoing issue which has
lasted for over two years we've served
an abank notice we've served two abank
notices on this company this company has
been very successful in actually batting
this off at court and been delaying and
delaying till we get to hear it in court
which hopefully should be later this
month however in two years the residents
of syno acoustic Improvement so they
have been subjected to this ongoing
statutory noise
nuisance for which we have the powers to
deal with and dealing it with us is
serving the abatement
notice it's rare that we serve two
abatement notices on the same company in
the same period but there seems to be
very little movement
cooperation uh from the company
concerned I'm concerned that I feel
we're not doing our best for the
residents but in the other hand our
hands are tied we can't do
anymore uh and I think it's important
that we do the best for the people that
we serve we are public servants and I
would like to explore what more we can
do and I will hopefully do that when
we're in court later this month that may
involve some sort of injunction that may
involve
us seeing what we can do and that always
comes at a risk because we're going to
be spending money on barers to go to
court to see if we can do things I would
like to protect the residents as much as
possible and I think it will be money
well spent but we will await the the
outcome of the court hearing later this
month and that will really determine how
we move forward the protection of the
residents is my primary concern and I'd
like to think we can do better than what
we we have done but a lot of that is in
the Court's hands because of the delay
and the delay and the delay which has
really not helped the residents in this
particular instance
hs2 we've got ongoing issues with hs2
and we're always going to have in all
honesty until such time uh that it's
really completed and all the ancillary
works are completed the tbms have have
nearly all finished now so the tunnel B
tunnel boring machines have nearly all
completed it's the ancillary Works uh
which are going on uh which can actually
be a bit of a delay so to prevent night
working we've allowed some additional
working uh of a Saturday and I think
we've just delayed some additional
working on a Sunday as well just to
prevent some night working I prefer
people to be disturbed in the day uh and
to get a good night's sleep sometimes we
have to
acknowledge that some working outside of
ours is going to be achievable and I can
safely say that my team have done their
best to try and prevent any night
working uh as a way
possible 2.3 Public Health bu
we're seeing a lot more we've seen the
doubling of the numbers uh for when we
compare the same period for last year
it's very sad uh that we're seeing the
numbers uh that we are seeing it costs
us the public uh about 1300 per Public
Health burial uh and when we're seeing
double the number that's double the
expense and the public purse is not a
infinite po
that money has to be found from
somewhere the risks of not doing that
are we we can't take that risk it is a
public health risk if we sadly don't put
take the appropriate steps at the
appropriate times to prevent disease and
that's what we're task to do and my team
will do that as as well as they can but
it does pose a risk moving forward if
the public don't meet their their
obligations and set out what they want
doing
uh when it comes to that sad time in the
life that means the council is going to
actually foot that bill
unfortunately but we have seen an
increase in numbers for
that private water samples uh we've
completed all of our private water
samples for this year uh so we've sent
those our annual return to the DWI with
the largest amount of data I think it
really tested the capacity of uh of our
it uh to to complete that but complete
it we
did however there is a caveat to that
and with some additional guidance which
has just come out it's likely that a few
other sites will be added to the private
water supply list so even when they get
Main's water and then it's redistributed
that may then be classified as private
water so we could see our private water
samples double uh next year if the DWI
guidance actually makes it to law so so
we could see a doubling of
that planning
consultations we do a lot and we used to
get involved in the technical aspects be
contaminated land or
Acoustics that does toe up our resources
for the
team it's nice to get in at the initial
stage if we can to prevent a nuisance
occurring at a later stage so prevention
is better than cure
but it does tie up our resources to do
that and it's important that members are
aware of
that uh dogs is uh seems to be quite
topical at the moment especially with
the EXL bully
restrictions I won't read it out uh
because it's it's there uh in front of
you but that legislation has come in now
uh we in the district we still haven't
seen an Exel uh we haven't collected one
and really should we be if it's a
dangerous dog anyway uh is that a police
matter or is it us you know if it's
straying and it's an offense for an EXL
po to stray uh and if it's not
microchipped if we collect it and we put
it into uh into one of the dog homes are
they going to accept it to start with
what is the consequences for that and if
I can tell you that our fee for
collecting a dog last year was 17 a day
uh that the the dog home would charge us
that fee has gone up to an initial fee
of £1
127 for the first day and then £47 per
day
thereafter so we're quite fortunate we I
think we had 24 26 St dogs last year uh
so the consequences
are are quite high for us but not as
high as some authorities that have a lot
of of stray dogs they're going to see a
a big Financial outlay from a dog point
of view moving
forward and that does pose a Financial
Risk to us uh again moving
forward the service request figures uh
are there in front of you nothing tends
to stand out for me uh in those figures
but I'm here should the members uh want
any additional
information moving on to
licensing uh the majority of our
licenses uh sort of go out in November
uh for the annual renewal fee and
additionally we've uh our de recovery
has been quite limited due to the fact
that we've got a lot of work to do so we
tend to think about getting the licenses
out undertaking the enforcement doing
the routine
inspections and the debt recovery is a
side which was mentioned in one of our
audits uh probably three or four years
ago we do do a uh a a debt recovery plan
throughout the year however the quieter
de December January uh period we tend to
try and recover as much as we can and
I'm really glad and I said this to my
officers only this morning that they've
recovered £225,000 this year uh which
would have gone outstanding our debt
recovery uh is is so good that our
outstanding balance at the time of
coming to this committee this morning uh
today is less than2
2,000 so uh that is all that is
outstanding at the moment and that's my
team and it's my licensing officers in
particular that have done an outstanding
job chasing invoices on top of their
day-to-day work and uh and I did thank
them uh for that and it's a it's a good
effort I don't like carrying debt uh I
don't like it in any way shape or form
uh however the officers have gone over
and above and collected quite a lot of
money this year so well done to them
they actually are involved the licensing
officers in the task and finish group uh
as well which are looking at license
premises uh which I think is a good
thing as well we should know where they
are and do our level best uh to sort of
keep up with them Anar is and private
higher uh the leveling up uh
regeneration bill was quite an
interesting read if you ever need to go
to sleep at night it's uh it is a very
interesting read uh however one of
issues in there was that uh it could be
a County Council function moving forward
in a ling up Bill uh which would mean
that we would lose the opportunity to
put an agid policy uh on there to vet
the drivers that wouldn't come to the
members but we would be subjected to
those that are at the County Council so
the County Council will be setting the
standard that standard may be the same
as the one we've got it may be less than
the one we've got the end cap rating for
our V Vehicles is high because we've got
an age policy uh the pollution from our
vehicles is better than most because
they're all euro6 vehicles and I can't
say that for for everyone uh so we may
lose some of that local option but it
may go to the county if this uh is
passed moving
forward uh Animal Welfare uh we've got
10 businesses outstanding at the moment
uh from an animal welfare which need to
get inspected by the to March we're well
on track and I'm happy that my team will
complete those
inspections there's nothing on here with
regards to our boat inspections this is
the time of the year that our boat
inspections are done because come Easter
the boats will be out and on the river
we have a new boat inspector and the
feedback that I got was very positive uh
from the new boat inspector uh this
morning uh and I will update members
more when I've got more hard facts with
regards to uh value for money uh and
what we're getting from the new Bo
inspector moving forward and finally our
scrap
metal unlicensed scrap metal dealer in
the
district uh people think they get away
with a variety of things we try to
enforce as much as we can using the
legislation that we've got uh and one
scrap metal collect
uh was contacted scen collecting we
brought him in for an interview we had a
chat I somebody felt the edge of his
shirt I think it was his collar uh they
got him in one of the enforcement
options for us is to take action take no
action do a
letter in this instance we gave him a
written warning he was asked to pay his
outstanding bill
which was a 12 month fee and that was
then backdated so if people get away
with nothing it sets a nice even Level
Playing Field for everybody to play by
uh and my officers thought that was the
best enforcement option in this
particular instance uh and I definitely
agreed with
them the figures are there for the
licensing issued over the last
quarter uh and the team down with a
total of 390 service requests since the
the last December meeting they've closed
off 377 requests therefore at the time
of writing this report there were 13
active service requests thank you
chair
move thanks thanks chair um just going
back to the uh service requests for eh
if we might um and the in particular the
the the
reduction from the same period last year
in the number requests seems to equate
with the reduction in the
planning um requests if you like um and
I I not I noted that you said it would
and we've spoken about this before it
would be uh it's ideal if you're
consulted at the earliest stage
considering that the the number of
requests in both cases in overall and
with planning seem to have gone down by
about
200 and we see planning applications
coming through at still a fair rate why
has that gone down P any thoughts on
that uh yeah yes I can definitely say
that has gone down to the fact that
we've highlighted this to planning the
planning department some of the planning
consultations that we actually deal with
uh in the past have been dare I say no
don't Paul uh I will nfnf and trivia uh
so from an environmental health point of
view I'm not concerned if they've got a
new window in there I'm not concerned uh
that the the fence is raised by a
certain amount it's a planning matter
it's a planning concern but it's not an
environmental health concern uh so the
reality is I think sometimes some of the
planners were sending us more than they
needed to and to be fair to them uh that
was mentioned to their manager so their
manager spoke to them and they're
sending less through to us now so we can
actually see the wood through the trees
we are dealing with the bigger more
medum more technical uh planning uh
applications so we're being consulted on
those
but we're they're not sending the the
more minor ones through so hence the
reduction in that
number um Public Health burials uh
usually I assume these are where people
have no netive kin as you say but that
doesn't mean mean to say that they don't
have an estate once they've gone do we
ever recover any expenses from the
Estates of these
diseased yes through the chair if they
do leave an estate we go over and above
to to do the best service possible for
the final stages of their life uh
because there's a strong likelihood that
the council will recover that cost so we
will try to put on a funeral uh for them
if the ca that's the case uh or the
crematorium and the public can attend uh
that however it is still there State and
we still need to be sensible in what
money we spend on the funeral uh but we
do it with a sense of
responsibility uh for that deceased
person so if they have an estate we
recover the money sometimes sadly that
recovery of that funds can take up to a
year sometimes even longer uh for the
estate to get sorted uh but a lot of the
time uh it is the fact that they have no
next of kin they have no money they have
no anything and it's quite sad to go
into
somebody's home to see a television one
chair and and a bin and a bed and it's
it's a sad reflection on life in all
honesty but in those cases we can't
recover that money so we undertake a
director creme uh uh cremation usually
because it's the cheapest option for the
public purse and I have to think about
the public purse because we can't be
seen to be wasting squandering money uh
but we still need to have a bit of
dignity with what we
do Could you um Paul tell me a bit more
about the difficulties you come across
in your in your private water
sampling and what happens when you have
a you know bad sample and describe to me
a bit about that
process yes thank you and through the
chair uh we we tend not to do the
samples ourselves anymore we've got a
trunk contractor that will go out and do
the water samples for us when those
water samples come back uh they're
either positive and everything's good
and they take all the boxes and meet all
the Criterion uh or they don't uh when
they don't we try to see what the issue
is uh and then if it's something which
can be addressed by a simple UV light a
filter or there other measures that need
to be undertaken in order to get that
sample up to a suitable drinking water
standard if we get the cooperation
fantastic uh however we're Duty Bound in
some cases to serve a notice to actually
make sure that the notice is served and
then the water standards come up to an
acceptable standard by a certain time uh
and that has to be a reasonable time
period the majority of the time that is
met and most people meet that standard
well within the time period which is set
for them to do so in the meantime while
they're coming up to that standard we
usually put her or do not drink the
water happy to wash and and do
everything else with it plus a toilet
but you will have bottled water until
such time that it comes out and that'll
be set on the notice so that's how those
that
witha thank you chair um I see you have
three Li um pavement licenses have been
uh given out over the year I was
wondering are those whereabouts are
those being um what areas are those for
because I was aware not so long ago
there was issues in High Street
counselors and uh I think residents
getting emotionally involved about
certain businesses being spilling out on
the pavement are those in those areas at
all thank you uh yes through the chair
uh I don't know exactly where those
three licenses are I should imagine the
majority of our pavement licenses are in
straford uh so I would imagine that they
they are there uh there's a process to
follow it's quite a straightforward
process it's it's online submit the
application the officers will look at
that and then deal with it accordingly
making sure that the standards can be
met and if members have got involved in
the past you're very correct in saying
that and we're here to give advice to
members before they give that advice out
to the public should they need it thank
you
thank you J as always Paul thank you
very much for very good reports um just
a few sort of comments if I can say um
picking up your comments on the
Christmas Victorian
Market um I read the SAG report I saw
your comments and I sensed your
frustration about
repeated offenses it was raised at some
length of overview and scrutiny and the
concerns were also raised at cabinet so
I think just to say that your those
comments in the SAG have not gone
unnoticed a number of members have
raised concerns as Council grott knows
to ensure that we the market to go ahead
again next year you'll be over it like a
rash
um um picking up the environmental noise
I just wonder you mentioned there's
nothing now that can be done until a
court case at the end of of March but I
wonder at the end after that court case
has been heard if it would be possible
for this Committee just to have a brief
update from you just so we know where we
are if that wouldn't be too much trouble
um third very just on the public health
burials
[Music]
um managing the the balance of dignity
and cost can I just ask does anyone from
the district council attend these public
funerals
and just my my last one is back on the
planning consultations um I think see
that some officer take undertaking
additional training which is great um Mr
B and I have spoken several times about
ensuring that we have sufficient budgets
for additional training because I think
it's a great way of increasing staff
retention uh increasing yeah ensuring
staff retention increasing skills making
the place a better place to work so I
think that I welcome that but I just
wonder as I mentioned the the P review
earlier on whether as part of the
planning service review we should look
at where some of these responsibilities
overlap should some of the stuff some of
the issues that are coming to
environment should they be dealt with
under under planning rather than coming
to you thank you thank you chair
uh thank you and through the chair I'll
sort of go those answers in reverse
order if I if I may uh planning
consultations I think the majority of
them should come through the plan
process uh in all honesty and I'd love
to say that I've got resources for an
officer to sit there and answer each and
every one reality is we we haven't uh
and the reality is you need it it took
me 20 years or so to get to grips with
the planning terminology the phrases all
the contaminated land the Acoustics and
to train staff when they're coming
through the system and I think you're
right you hit the nail on the head it's
get the recruitment right get the
retention right and then get the
development right so we've attracted
them we've got them we've trained them
now let's move them that step forward
let's expose them to to other things
people see uh environmental planning as
as a chore a difficult subject
especially when you're looking at
contaminated land and Acoustics
especially it is very
specialized but we're ehos and you know
we've got a broad brush degree but we
definitely need that additional training
to sort of bring us up to the standard
that is needed so we can happily deal
with the Consultants that we're up
against uh on both of those fronts and
the needed to actually share some of
that knowledge with the planners we have
the experience in the team uh I would
say that there's three of us that are
good uh one in particular is very good
and it's sharing that knowledge with the
team and exposing them to things and
developing them so we're more rounded
we're more complete uh and I think
that's what we need to do and I think
we're doing that very I think we're
doing that very well but I would say
that because I'm the boss uh so uh uh so
I think that that's one uh attendance
that public barrial uh we used to attend
uh we don't anymore there's a cost to to
opening uh it up to the public so we
don't attend uh anymore so we're trying
to reduce that
cost uh an update on the noise case I
can happily do that and I can bring that
back to the next committee uh if you
want or do you want something
sooner yeah right of that I can I can
make that happen I will do
that okay I I will send that out uh and
the the Christmas Victorian Market I
can't remember what the question
was it was less of a question than a
comment that your concerns had been
noted yeah yeah and thank you for that
and it's important I chair the SAG
committee uh Although our powers of a of
a sag are nil uh in all honesty and they
are nil it's a it's a group of
professionals Poli ampl fire emergency
planning local Authority uh and highways
in some cases who get together to give
the applicants the best advice to make
their events as safe as possible that's
what we're about we want to encourage
events into our district but they
definitely need to be safe so we offer
advice on that if they're not safe then
individuals in the SAG can take the
appropriate action should they see fit
uh and we will endeavor to make every
event as safe as possible but some
events this one in particular sort of
goes beyond my remit because we are a
partner in it so from a health and
safety point of view that event would
come under the hsse to to actually
enforce I do pass on my knowledge skills
uh to those in the markets team and my
head of service who I have to say has
done such a good job in actually trying
to move this event forward uh and and I
take my hat off to her uh for doing that
and it's nice that you've acknowledged
that and it's nice that the thoughts of
the Professionals in the SAG of actually
being listened to so thank you for that
counselor thanks chair um just if you
wouldn't mind Paul at the last meeting
there was a a couple of items on there
uh one was to do with the the uh Food
business and this was the facility they'
still got the facility to produce milk
um this is and you were saying then that
you keep the committee informed of
progress in the case I wonder if we
could just have an update on that um and
the second one if you don't mind was
um to do with I think it was from memory
it was to do with a gun club and a
shooting club of some kind
um and noise shooting ground Farm here
we go and we sent we served uh Community
protection warning letters on both the
shooting ground and the land owner and I
wondered whether that has now resolved
and gone away as
well thanks Paul thank you and then
through the chair ify May uh going from
the last one
first it's really going to be we need to
wait out on the shooting range one it's
s of close season at the moment they're
not going to be doing uh a fat lot until
the spring uh as and when they do that
it will resurrect itself and we will be
in a position to obtain evidence and to
progress and move that forward as and
when I've made a note in the book as and
when uh that does uh raise its ugly head
once more I will I will let you know
with regards to the Food business and
the milking parlor uh the FSA uh did
serve a notice to prevent him from being
registered uh as a as as a milk producer
uh I do know that his family have made
contact with my staff about getting him
back up uh to to
milking there's always some hoops for
people to jump through when you
undertake a food
business those
Hoops were put at a low level in some
cases due to the a of the person person
concerned how often the staff have been
dealing with
him
however the bar has been raised the
Hoops have been raised the standards
have been raised if he does want to
produce milk moving forward he will need
to take every box before we will permit
that thank you chair yeah I just really
was um I think you've already answered
the question in response to um the
Curtis but it was just really discuss
the um health and safety issues of the
victoriia market which should be be
discussed at cabinet and osc um and just
our relationship with being a regulatory
Authority and the health and safety in
but you've already answered that thank
you very
much if I if I could just to clarify
that point and just to drill that point
home the Christmas Victoria Market is
part of the market uh forum and the
markets cont contract because we're a
partner the district council can't
enforce on itself so therefore I have no
enforcement Powers as I do on every
other event which we're not a partner of
uh so yes it's definitely an advisory
and it would be the HSC that would be
investigating anything if anything were
to happen thank
you are there any other comments or
questions on this
item thank
you we move on to item nine any urgent
business there is no urgent business so
I declare the meeting ended at 5 to
4 thank you